what's going on guys in this video we're
about to break down the spoilers for
mayhew academia chapter 336 in which
there was yet another twist in the uh
traitor storyline during the chapter
last week it was heavily implied the
invisible girl had been the traitor this
whole time and those of you who follow
me on twitter will know that i didn't
think she was a good choice my reasoning
was that hagakure has always been one of
the most irrelevant background students
about on the same level as koda and her
actually being the traitor due to her
invisibility it seemed almost too easy
to be satisfying however that being said
the spoilers for chapter 336 have now
made the whole situation a lot more
interesting and in this video i'll
explain why this latest twist makes
perfect sense
just before we get into it though don't
forget to sub to the channel if you
haven't already and drop a like as well
if you want to see more content like
this
okay so the title of this chapter is
villain and according to the leaks it
begins with deku and bakago training
bakugou is testing out his new cluster
attack that he mentioned last week and
this involves him producing multiple
spheres of sweat and then exploding them
simultaneously for that reason he's
wearing his winter costume in this
chapter to increase sweat production
even though in the manga right now is
technically spring some of the other
students were also training in
preparation for their inevitable fight
with all for one with shoto trying to
improve control over both sides of his
power as this is going on kaminari says
to mineta that their chance of winning
the war is greater than ever considering
that shiguraki was significantly
weakened after starring stripe deleted a
bunch of his quirks
on top of that giganto machia is
currently asleep and imprisoned but
bakugo claims that denki is being way
too optimistic although the heroes got a
slight advantage thanks to what star and
stripe did bakago points out that all
for one is still impossible to find
shiguraki was already weakened before he
faced star and he still won and finally
the villains likely have multiple plans
and are just waiting for the right
moment to attack
because of all this bakugou believes the
best thing they can do right now is just
to prepare for the villains to strike
but on the flip side deku says he wants
to go out into the wild and search for
afo
after that whole discussion is over the
chapter moves on to her gary in the
forest as she observes three people
talking from a distance the three people
in question are aoyama and his parents
and remember ever since the war really
kicked off the parents of ua students
have been living on campus alongside
their kids
as invisible girl watches on one of
aliyama's parents says that he has to
obey because someone is giving them
instructions again they tell their son
that he just needs to keep doing what
he's always done as the bad things he's
been up to have been disguised as
everyday actions and are impossible to
trace his mother states that they need
to keep obeying all for one or else
they'll be killed but aliyama starts
crying and basically says he doesn't
want to do it his parents quickly
replied that they're not doing it
because they like it but it's way too
late to go against afo
meanwhile hagakuri has just been there
completely invisible listening to
everything they're saying and after
hearing what they said she obviously
realizes that aoyama must be the traitor
and she starts sticking back to the
villain attacks on the usj and on the
training camp in season 3. apparently
the reason she followed him into the
forest this chapter was that ever since
the war he's been quite depressed and
even after deku came back to school he
hasn't smiled once consequently she
followed him to see if he was okay and
in doing so she's now accidentally
stumbled across his darkest secret
as the ioma family continued to talk we
learned that back in the day their son
was born quirkless which is why they
made a deal with afo in the first place
to me this makes perfect sense for so
many reasons with the first one being
that all for one has been using this
exact same business model for decades we
saw in a flashback to his younger days
that he would recruit followers by
either giving them quirks or taking them
away and that's how he was able to gain
a ton of friends over the years
in addition to that the whole storyline
with lady nagant showed us that when he
gives someone a quirk he can somehow
booby trap that person so that they
literally explode once they start going
against him
therefore my theory right now is that as
part of the deal they made with afo
ariama's parents were booby trapped
exactly like lady nagant and all for one
can detonate them at any time if yuga
doesn't do what he says
the reason why this traitor reveal is so
much better than it being invisible girl
is that there's actually been a ton of
setup when it comes to this character
for a long long time aoyama has been
sassed for varying different reasons
whether it be his weird coding messages
to deku him going missing during the usj
attack or the fact that he's canonically
described as someone who doesn't go out
of his way to make friends
those are definitely all things that
have contributed to aoyama's
mysteriousness and knowing what we know
now we can re-contextualize some of the
things he said one example is that in
chapter 168 he tells deku that they're
alike and in hindsight you could argue
that this is harikoshi planting a clue
that they both receive power that
derives from all for one
a different example is that when
midoriya left ua everyone else was
making phone calls or inquiries so they
could locate deku and bring him back but
aoyama was the only student to offer a
different point of view
rather than bringing midoriya back
aoyama implied that maybe they don't
need to worry so much because deku was
with the adults which to me was his
subtle way of discouraging everyone from
going after izuku he likely didn't want
midoriya to return so he could avoid
this exact situation that he's in now
because now that midoriya is out uh all
for one is giving him orders to betray
his classmates once again
besides this aoyama receiving a quirk
from afo explains why naval laser is so
incompatible with his body because he
was never built to have this power he
mentioned in season 4 how without his
support item the laser used to sometimes
burst out randomly not to mention that
he would often have a bad reaction when
it came to using it
given that different people react in
different ways to receiving a power that
isn't theirs yugos struggling in this
way was some great foreshadowing from
hirokoshi for the reveal that we got in
this chapter
another clue worth considering is that
during the maike academia exhibition
earlier this year we got this image of a
sad aoyama sitting in front of a twisted
looking monster which yeah i mean this
was a massive indication of the trait to
reveal his expression in this image
implied he wasn't happy about the
situation and now that we have the full
context we know that he's depressed
since he's only doing this to save his
own parents
that's why during the forest training
camp he did still go against the
villains and save his friends or at
least save tokyami and the reason he did
that is because in his heart he's still
a good person it's just that he's been
put in this impossible situation where
he either has to do bad things or his
parents will explode most likely so yeah
it's not easy now back to the spoilers
her gakueri realizes that she needs to
warn a teacher but suddenly she sees
someone else approaching
meanwhile aoyama is still crying to his
parents saying that he's been suffering
this whole time and dedicated himself to
this persona so he wouldn't be so
consumed by the guilt
back when afo was arrested in kamino he
thought that he could finally live
peacefully with his friends but as we
know he was wrong his parents apologized
and yuga says that he did all of this to
protect them as he didn't want them to
die they then ask him to keep protecting
them but it's at this moment that deku
arrives having been brought over by
invisible girl midoriya says that
hugakurei told him something about the
traitor and asked if this is true but
aliama's parents tried to play dumb
at the same time yuga himself is crying
non-stop while looking at deku and
blames himself for not saying anything
when they rescued him in case you might
have forgotten what ayama is referring
to here is when class won a rescue deku
from dictator and also from himself and
during that interaction literally every
member of class a said something to
azuku except for aoyama even the most
irrelevant members of the class at least
got to say one word whether it be koda
sero or odoro or invisible girl everyone
said something except this guy and as
we've established this is partly because
he secretly didn't want deku to come
back but also probably because he was
feeling guilty
midoriya says that he went into the
forest to search for aoyama since he
realized something was wrong and this is
when the traitor properly breaks down
and starts confessing everything he's
done he calls himself a disgusting
villain and reveals that it was him who
leaked information about the training
camp and the usj while deku just has
this huge look of disappointment on his
face
the final panel of this chapter is a
flashback to the cheese he left on
midori's balcony in season 4 and that
chi spelled out the words i know
considering this chapter has given
things a whole new context it's almost a
certainty that this message from aoyama
was him confirming his knowledge about
one for all
finally we should probably address why
nezu got it so wrong when it came to who
the traitor might be according to him
none of the kids displayed any weird
behavior since being in the dorms and
this was the main reason why he assumed
that none of them could be the spy
the problem is that until this chapter
the traitor never needed to do anything
since being in the dorms since
historically the spy has only leaked
information when necessary to allow the
villains to bypass ua security this
happened during the usj when the
villains received the teaching schedule
and it also happened during the forest
training camp when the villains also
received the gps coordinates of the
secret location so clearly aoyama has
been doing this stuff when needed but
he's not the traitor all the time he's
not constantly doing bad things so the
fact that he wasn't suspicious in the
four months since being in the dorms
that didn't really prove anything
in reality he was able to go about his
daily life without causing too much
suspicion and it's only now that he's
being called upon again
anyway let me know in the comments down
below what do you think of this reveal
do you prefer it to invisible girl or do
you think it should have still been her
i mean i'm very happy with the way this
has turned out i definitely did not want
it to be invisible girl it just felt way
too boring uh but this you know the
reasoning we get for aliyama the hints
we've gotten it just makes perfect sense
i also think that on top of all of this
there is still one more trait to be
revealed and that person is nezu because
if you see my video on this i am like
99.999
sure that nezu is a creation of dr graki
and all for one so if that's the case
you could have aoyama who is the traitor
that knows he's the traitor and you
could have nezu who's the traitor who
has no idea that he is
as always if you haven't already then be
sure to smash that sub button for more
videos like this and until the next one
peace out